Yes, hold it with your right hand-
ran
[music]
Just like
that, you can fix the military commander
.
I wish I could tell you about
it But there's a hold 4 that girl is holding right now
Yes, that mountain That's how it's done Intermediate route It's
not strange at all The
important thing is how to use your body for gold
It's fine if both hands are about the same weight as me The
important thing is whether or not you can feel
the moral pleasure  The feeling
of running Climbing has the correct way to move your body for each rock There is a proper way to
solve
it A game where you hit it and hit it
This is exactly what
Chiba Pan is
arrived